have a good time up to the sky
[Music]
we got a sparkle I'm counting down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking gonna have
a good time hands up to the sky we gonna
get roasted
I've been feeling it all day I wanna let
it go I wanna lose drops oh I'm ready to
roll and I've been dreaming about this
[Music]
[Music]
morning millenials welcome back to the
morning toast we are back hope everyone
had a lovely Martin Luther King a long
weekend it was lovely to have the day
off it was so lovely to have a long
weekend I love that we're coming back
with a four-day work week there's just
no better feeling in the world I just
didn't even realize it was a four-day
work week because I don't have said this
so many times and I probably jinx myself
but I do think I would look back on my
career and this will be the single most
important week of my life
camcos - and it's a short week that's so
you know of course like doing the little
doing the most in the littlest amount of
time we have Kim to us tickets presale
today I'm wearing my cam to expect her
to get into the spirit and general
general public on sale on Wednesday your
struggle having a stroke
Wednesday night I'm performing at
Caroline's can't wait to see you guys
there Thursday I'm performing at Bergen
PAC and I will be filming that show
which I'm really excited about and then
Saturday I'm at the Beacon Theater and
you know what I've got a tickle in my
throat and I'm worried about it um
you're gonna self care like we might
have to like move hot water with lemon
we might have to move shows around this
week if she needs to sleep in like TBD
will have shows for you everyday
obviously but like the priority is the
beacon I'm sorry no and I've been having
nightmares for the last two weeks about
it I can't ever heard of it yeah I don't
know look it up sweetie it's like small
little theater I had York City it's like
this liberal like arts like school you
know I had a nightmare about the beacon
last night and I've been having them all
week and it's just it's like you're
running yes by the way I'm having the
same types of dreams are you some
nightmares about my wedding that like it
was the wedding and everything was going
wrong and I couldn't get it back and
that's exactly the type of dreams I'm
having about the weekend I mean I think
that's really normal get used to them
for the next few nights and then it'll
all be behind you and we will be talking
about the show in hindsight isn't that
crazy oh by the way it's so crazy and
like I'm really looking forward to like
the curtain closing you know yes like
that's gonna be like the best moment of
my life we have a big party planned a
party it's just gonna be it's all gonna
be so fun but your nails are so long
your hair is so long I'm so jealous of
all like you're my
things growing yeah because my nails are
all broken my hair is all short I have
the sore throat and like I'm looking
like a ratchet like Barbie doll over
here no I it's okay I'm s like look
better than I feel I was starting to
allude to last week like I'm not really
feeling myself yes I remember um but
today is like the first day of getting
back to being snatchy oh speaking of
being snatched this natural new episode
is up cloudy and I do not watch about
jost night we won't be talking about it
today maybe we'll talk about it tomorrow
maybe not so if you want to talk all
things bachelor head over to this
snatchler heard on that episode I'm
gonna listen because um I haven't caught
up with the snitch and I feel like I
learned more about her on the snatchler
than I do when I FaceTime her yeah no I
I know everything about the snaps are
just based on our face times ya know but
there's things in there that she doesn't
tell her own sister she only tells
snatcher Meishan right but she loves a
good face time oh she loves it and she
loves to hang up on a face time oh my
god Dodie yeah I know Jackie and I were
both in Mexico this weekend which was
just such a weird coincidence too we're
acquaintances we were supposed to be on
the same flight second leg yeah we told
you guys how excited we were but I took
a later flight I was just not well the
third everyone on the plane was asking
about you I was like you guys would have
loved her like oh my god I'm so excited
to meet you when you were up at five
o'clock you were like I just got home
and I was like still in Detroit like I
wanted to die I know but I don't like so
great about me choices Mexico is such a
beautiful country and I'm like damn why
don't we ever go there more oh now I
know why it's so hard to get to
it's really like a West Coast it's like
the Miami of the west coast so I get why
and everyone on my trip was pretty much
from LA so I get why people go it's so
easy and I was like damn it was really
so beautiful and I was like I would
totally make here more except it took me
12 hours to get home so hard to get to
the west side of Mexico you can go to
the east side but then you're going to
Cancun and it's like we're not spring
breakers no so no Cabo I'd never been to
goggle before maybe they're no stunning
literally dining setting and the hotels
were like so well done and it's just
every time I go to Mexico Mike I should
go more and then I go in the flight home
I'm like never mind
yeah or if you want to go more like you
have to go for a long stretch of time
because yeah that's the only way like a
12 hour travel day is worth it no it was
so treacherous I know everyone's like
dying to know my my trip
Gwyneth was not there like I showed up
and they're like when it's in a calm I'm
like what so tink you pack your bags and
go no I was like I traveled 12 hours for
you people for you nobody you know it
was it was actually so much fun and like
the reason I switch my flight is because
it's like a really like scheduled out
weekend it's like there's a lunch party
there's a night party there's what and
so the third night is always like the
best night and it was a white party and
they flew in all the staff and food from
Bagatelle San Tropez and they were like
the bottle service like and like I
wasn't waking up at 7:00 a.m. to get on
the plane I just wasn't because it was
2:00 a.m. and my eyes were rolling to
the back of my head so like me been
really drunkenly on the beach like
bought some Delta flight that took us
through Detroit um and you know what I'm
not even upset because I had the best
night like it was so much fun you know
what like I didn't remind of energy I'm
such like a bad partier because I'm like
tired after five minutes especially with
the dancing but I was like it was like
my wedding I was I got the dance floor
all night like really just like turning
the place up it was it was stunning it
was your wedding week this is my wedding
week it was probably a response hold me
to party so much but I had such a good
time I have absolutely no regrets you
know what you only live once truly and
just like you said this is the most
important month and like if you only
half ask at all of the important things
including partying then like you'll look
back and be like oh why didn't I put the
pedal to the metal no I am like giving
150% to everything this week and mark my
word it's like on Sunday this week like
you will not hear from me should we take
off Monday I think so anyways I'm so
happy to be back though honestly I feel
like so much stuff happened but I was so
unplugged um like I didn't watch the SAG
Awards but I obviously have analyzed
that picture of Brad and Jen like we're
zoomed all the way the SAG Awards were
televised I thought it was like one of
those quiet ones
no you watched him last year and I
remember you said that he were impressed
by them I think was like Megan Mullally
he hosted oh she's great yeah yeah
they're always like us like they because
no one really expects much I think
people really enjoy them the fashion was
totally there there you know who I've
been loving has been doing on his
Instagram stories is Brad Goreski
I'm just taking high quality images on
his Instagram story being like we love
it or we hate it and it's a great way to
see all the outfits because like just
being on Twitter and stuff like you're
not gonna find everything so great plug
for red rubies Instagram did he make any
comments or he's just asking how we feel
he was just asking I'm gonna need
commentary yeah you know Scottie Cunha
does one too and he's a [ __ ] savage
that's what I need sorry yeah it's
really funny speaking of Brad Goreski
I read Gary janetti's book on the way to
Cabo and I was crying really crying
laughing oh my god it was so funny so
quick so good so smart I'm
ready ready for book two because it only
covers like up until the point he
doesn't even talk about once he started
getting successful is really just about
like New Year's where he was like either
a kid or like struggling but if we just
suffered through the struggling years we
want the rich it's too I want to hear
the rich stories at each chapter it's
like a collection of stories oh my god I
was crying when he talks about being a
waiter and having to sing happy birthday
but because he wasn't like he never
joined other waiters when they were
singing the Happy Birthday song would
you join for him I was literally had
tears coming out of my that's so money
now I'm gonna read it I'm happy think
you would love it guys it's so like
short quick it's perfection it's just
like a perfect little like piece of
candy right it's so cute in yellow to
the book well I would read it on my
Kindle I wouldn't know and then I
started reading the book that I was
talking about that Rebecca said it's her
favorite book called I and pilgrim and I
was like okay let me worry about like a
woman's journey on the way Mayflower
not that CIA CIA spy novel like post
9/11 terrorism it's [ __ ] crazy it's
so long at 700 pages
oh we had him only halfway through I'm
just like I had no idea what I was
reading right I'm really enjoying it
because it's a really good book but like
for the first like I don't know 10% I
thought it was about a woman and then
they used to pronoun I was like this is
a man Oh what yeah because I thought
like I don't know I just assumed I am
Billy Graham yeah I just I guess we just
picture pilgrims as women yeah it was
just it's crazy is it it's really good I
would recommend it is multiple pilgrim
pilgrim a pilgrim pilgrim sequel book
but it's only one cover
okay towards the end of the show we got
a ton of questions we're gonna do a
quick segment at the end about cam shows
about people haven't been and they just
have questions about it we got all your
questions from Instagram so if you're
watching live and you have any questions
you want to ask ask us about camp toast
head over to our Instagram story and
we'll do a little Q&A at the end of the
episode to get you all ready to go for
camp toast because at 12 o'clock tickets
go on sale on patreon we have no idea if
they're gonna fill out or not so um want
to guarantee that you got a ticket I
would head over to patreon.com I advise
otherwise tomorrow at noon yeah okay so
should should we I felt like I guess I
guess right I don't like have the time
look looking around okay go for it it's
doing for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your
tose and it feels very appropriate that
today's episode will be brought to you
by Sanford because my weekend was
brought to you by Sanford but when
you're hanging out with cool people in
LA can't be all smelly so I'd like
little purses with all my little stunts
bird perfumes it was really just a
premium experience have you ever gone up
to someone and asked you smell amazing
what perfume you're wearing
scent its most powerful since you have
it can bring on a flood of memories
influence your mood and of course
enhance your natural style but while
you're looking for that signature scent
that will make you stand out and keep
the memory of you lingering on your
tastes can be expensive and buying a
full bottle of perfume anytime you want
to try something new can be a hit or
miss with scent bird you can have great
taste and mix up your fragrance routine
without breaking the bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci or Versace
sent bird calm keeps you smelling good
month after month sandbar is a luxury
fragrance subscription service for
perfumes and colognes that has more than
600 designer brands for you to choose
from every month choose the perfume you
on a tribe and they'll send you a 30 day
supply if you're not sure but a percent
you're looking for you can sort and find
your new fragrance by brand style
occasion season and more plus they have
products from other categories like
skincare wellness and makeup they carry
brands like Aparri glam glow glow recipe
tart and many others and with our
exclusive offer just for our listeners
you can get 30% off your first month
today that's only ten dollars for your
first fragrance make sure you have the
new offer you guys it's Sandburg dot-com
/ Dean and the promo code is Steen for
30% of your first month that's SCE Mt
bird com / Steen to sign up and use our
promo code Steen ste n to find your
first perfume or cologne for just $10
don smell amazing I freaking love
Sanford I love signing on it and I love
smelling amazing I really love salt
anyways okay
first story jennifer aniston Brad Pitt
break the internet majorly 2020 SAG
Awards with the hand holding and then
the subsequent him watching her speech
right which Jason Kennedy for me was the
one lucky enough to capture oh my god
okay let's try Rupp being in the right
place at the right time exactly let's
take it from the top like these pictures
of them like holding hands being so
happy to see each other it's just like
sort of what we've been manifesting for
the past year have we I like don't ship
this really no I don't ship it because
and I actually I was looking at jarred
frites Instagram he posted something
like so pertinent where he was like
imagine your friend came to brunch one
morning she was like I'm thinking about
getting back together with my ex who
cheat who cheated on me with
one of our friends left to have a bunch
of kids with her and now wants to get
back together you wouldn't be like yes
we Stan no one like the whole internet
championing Jennifer Aniston and Brad
Pitt like I love Brad Pitt but like what
he did to Jen was wrong and like she has
way too much self-respect like and why
are we championing her like she won an
award and all we can talk about it's
like she's holding hands with her
ex-boyfriend like how little do we think
of her know like I think we think very
highly of her and it's just like we all
have just forgotten what happened
I just don't ship like at all from his
perspective or from hearse I know like I
know like what he did to her was
terrible be like I love him so much and
like I just I just don't see her with
him or him with her it's just really
complicated like what he did was so
awful but I love him so much
it's just how does America's Sweetheart
do like the most vile thing is he still
America's Sweetheart yes yes but it's
like I mean I just I stand Brad Pitt
like till the day I die but I do not
recommend this relationship for either
of them no I don't either but I
recommend happiness for both of them and
it's like that's what that hand-holding
is it's a bit of happiness then that's
what they should have
you know what just sucks is like so
Jennifer Aniston got broken up with what
20 years ago about 10 10 and she's been
on the cover of every magazine as it
pertains to her ex-boyfriend for the
last ten years and I almost felt like we
were starting to get out of it but then
like he got divorced like now this
picture and like she just bought herself
another ten years on the cover of Us
Weekly no it's so crazy like Us Weekly
it's gonna feast for years over the
years like the story was almost coming
to an end like kind of but now it's like
we're not even close her and Brad are
like tabloid trash fodder for the next
ten years and I hope she's happy with
herself I mean I really do seems really
happy with herself she seems so happy
and like just bright and like exuding
she won yeah for the morning show host
you up against um hazel oh I guess a
female actor in a drama series yeah that
would also be crown people yeah well
it's a tough category yeah shocking
really shocking but she is great on that
show yeah she did win the Golden Globe
though no okay um yeah and he won two
which is like bodes really well for the
Oscars each time he makes a speech it's
just like chilling huh
and I can go for an Oscar speech from
him like just because this is a
and we're ever gonna hear from him
unless he chooses to do another podcast
like ours I know their habit but we
don't get to hear from him so like this
is just such a tree
it's a window into the life of Brad Pitt
has shed who is Bradley Pitt I don't
know he's just I think honestly he's a
simple man with simple needs and just
with a big heart and it wants it and he
wants to share and it needs a simple
girl yeah so unfortunately I don't think
that includes you and I oh no no no I
wouldn't suggest myself oh I wouldn't
suggest it's so hard we do this all the
time he's like he's the eternal bachelor
Jennifer Lawrence yeah but when it comes
to Jennifer Aniston like just really
quick rebuttal um I was in Mexico this
weekend and I guess the Netflix in
Mexico is different than Netflix in
America and they still have friends and
I just want to say my life was so much
better like shame on Netflix for doing
that to us but soon it's coming back
yeah legio mac how long are we gonna
talk about it I don't know just like we
talked about these things and it feels
like they're never gonna happen in then
one day they just pop up right like
Disney Plus right have you tried doesn't
even us
oh we have it I didn't see anything that
I wanted to like sit down to commit to
but I think I'm gonna watch the High
School Musical reboot because I've heard
a really good thing I mean that song
that went viral on tick-tock from it is
so good it's having heard it oh [ __ ]
it's gonna bother me it's really good
it's like this beautiful song okay I
remember it's really good okay I'm
excited to watch it also I felt like I
was on the set of HSM to this weekend
and it really got me like no it's just
the whole place looked like bet on it it
was crazy but it wasn't film there no
and it just really got me in the mood
for some hsm also like Zac Efron Vanessa
Hudgens like being very this similar to
the they're like the younger Brad Pitt
and Jennifer Aniston and honestly the
people championing both these
relationships is e-news and they have to
stop because like I don't really ship
Zac Efron and Vanessa Hudgens
Vanessa Ann Hudgens excuse me I don't
well like why are we why are we
championing people to go back to
relationships like they ended for a
reason I don't know like maybe they will
talk about to grow you know maybe they
had to go their own way okay but now
they're all in this together I don't
know maybe maybe obviously it sounds
right it does okay
next story is just there's been a lot of
crazy like Mexicans over the weekend but
we're getting to a place of we know
where we stand
and Harry made a speech on Sunday night
he went to an event and he addressed
what was going on now I didn't watch the
speech but I read a transcription so and
this was after the Queen released a
statement that they will be no longer
His Royal Highness in Her Royal Highness
so the Duke of Sussex has said he is
taking a leap of faith and stepping back
from being a senior royal adding there
was really no other option speaking at
an event on Sunday evening Prince Harry
said he and Megan had hoped to continue
serving the Queen but without public
funding unfortunately that wasn't
possible he said it was oh I guess like
they didn't want the public's money
because they probably wanted to make
their own money but he couldn't do that
while still being right they wanted the
best of both worlds right so it was his
first speech since the couple said they
wanted to stand down from being
full-time working Royals the prince said
he had found the love and happiness that
I had hoped for all my life with Megan
and he wanted to make it clear that they
were not worth walking away okay a lot
of people were very moved by his speech
he talks about you know how the country
and the people have always you know been
like so supportive of him taking him in
as their own like after a princess died
um died Princess died died right um and
he says like they had no other choice he
alludes at one point to it being the
media being the reason but he never
really explains what what sort of
position they were backed into where
they had no other choice right I mean
again this is like Mike Ross Tamara in
this lifetime as I really have no idea
how I feel on the situation like are
they throw sponsors or do they just want
to real life and she's just like a mom
and the dad protecting their son I truly
don't know um all I have to say it's
like she's being paparazzi now like
walking their dogs and carrying the baby
and it's like that's the life she wanted
and that's life she got go you sis you
can call the paps now cuz you live on
private property yeah I'm I'm I'm okay
I'm better than I was last week over
this like and the Queen seems okay and I
feel like where everything where the
chips are falling where they're where
they may like I think the monarchy is
gonna be okay and that's really my
concern yeah you know I think at the end
of the day as long as we let the chips
fall where they may
I think we'll be okay I know and that's
truly how I feel and also as long as
like the monarchy is intact I guess I'm
just like social royalist who knew I
know but you know what like I don't
think the monarchy could ever not be yes
it could you just wake up one day and
it's like and no it has no legitimacy
because people are just coming and going
as they please well that's
true okay I look at other countries
where like there it's not like it is in
Britain there's a reason here in C
theory um this is totally unfounded but
I did read it that and I guess this has
been a popular conspiracy theory for a
while it was that Charles is not Harry's
dad oh yes you've spoken about that yeah
no and so Natalie part of the reason
that they're leaving her and they're
letting them leave is because he's not a
real royal and he was gonna like expose
expose the DNA test like get his 23andme
so that's just what I heard but again
conspiracy there he total alleged yeah
we've discussed that theory before about
that other guy who looks just like Harry
being his dad and I I wasn't convinced
no when you see pictures of Harry and
William when they're kids like they're
totally brothers but I also think you
could like find someone that looks like
you and be like Oh Madeline pitch like
yeah she's my long-lost Angelo but I
guess like there was never any like
thing linking right that guy who like
was and like not to you know speak ill
of the dead but Ana was quite quite
promiscuous uh yeah I'll know once they
showed in the crown Harry is like the
Khloe Kardashian for sure but like where
do you stand on that I see on the fact
that like Khloe Kardashian is like
totally correct she's the most
Kardashian of them all she started the
Kardashian like vibe baby he's not a
Kardashian that know whatever oh can we
speak really quickly about Mason Disick
being on tik-tok sure um and how he's
you know there's the hype house yeah for
those who don't know one tick tocks like
all these popular tick stalkers moving
into like a mansion in West Hollywood
no sorry Beverly Hills and they like me
content together and like everyone just
like is so you know caught up in the
hype house like they call themselves a
high pass they have their own tick-tock
some of them are like thirty million
followers so now there's a new tick tock
house called the ysb house it's like the
young sibling brother house or something
Mason Disick is in it Jaden Smith is in
it lives in a house I think it might
just be like a club I don't think this
one is like a physical house but david
dobrik who obviously everyone knows did
a tick-tock this weekend with Kourtney
and Mason kind of announcing Mason's
arrival and you have to watch Mason's
tic TOCs like I was watching some of
them it was so crazy because for some
reason I just like when I see him and we
don't hear him talk I just assumed that
he like is a 30 year old man who like
goes to clubs Jackie he's here Jackie
went one year when you're watching his
to talk you realize that he is nothing
of the sort
he's a kid he's such a kid like he's so
weird like no but it's like it's
reassuring I honestly assumed like he
likes growing up too fast on like PJs
with Scott like going to Miami like J
going to the clubs like going to like
lids and he recently like shot up like
you really think they must like a 30
year old man cuz he's so tall but you
watch his take talks and he's like
vlogging and this like it was just a
normal kid he's American campers totally
taste tic TOCs are [ __ ] premium I
really hope everyone goes and watches
them and now Courtney Santiago yes cuz
like Mason made her be on it's actually
hilarious seeing like kids celebrities
who's like kids make them we go on Tech
Talk yeah I mean I'm all for this if it
means that in more Kardashian Jenner's
yeah I don't take talk and we get more
content I feel like North would have a
tick tock totally I'm sure she has a
thick fog private a private one okay
well we'll keep you posted on Harry I'm
Megan like I'm this is just the
beginning but I'm glad that it's to be
the end of the first chapter you know
emmalin and we all know how to move
forward from this and I'm feeling like a
lot better and more settled about it and
I do look forward to seeing what they do
because you know that's what we do on
the show is talk about interesting
people doing interesting things so I
hope it's interesting it seemed like
things have quieted down yeah now this
paparazzi picture of her where like her
baby Joe and it's like a little unhooked
like people are like mom she's like who
[ __ ] cares but she's also like
walking two dogs at the same time like
it does seem a little dangerous but
again not here mom shame just pointing
out the facts she's got a lot on your
plate she's got a lot on our plate but
she was looking snatch I wonder if she
was wearing thrive cosmetics for sure
she was thrive cosmetics products are
made with high performance skin loving
ingredients and clinically proven
formulas that highlight your best
features with long-lasting wear all
products are formulated without parabens
sulfates and fluff lights they are 100%
vegan and cruelty free but the best part
about thrive Cosmetics is that they give
back they have a mission that is truly
bigger than Beauty for every products
purchase to thrive Cosmetics donates to
help women thrive with a responsive
giving mission that supports nonprofit
partners with the donation of funds or
products their causes include women
emerging with from homelessness
surviving domestic abuse and women
fighting cancer so it's just the best of
both worlds in the words of Hannah
Montana you can buy something knowing
that your money is going to a good cause
and then also you get snatched make up
products like they're green mascara is
just
everything you guys like I have been
suffering ever since I burned my
eyelashes off I'm in the Utah fireplace
gate of 2018 and I just haven't come
back from me epitaph Cosmetics is a
really helping name um but we have an
offer for you guys when you have so many
offer when you have so many choices when
it comes to beauty products check out
thrive Cosmetics I think you guys will
really enjoy it
start thriving help women in need today
by going to thrive cosmetics dot-com /
toast and use the code toast for 15% off
your first purchase
that's thrive ca us e m e TI CS dot-com
/ toast code toast for 15% off thrive
Cosmetics calm / toast code toast PETA
certified as completely vegan and
cruelty free chit chit chat chit check
it out
sign on check it out freaking love
thrive okay love to thrive this next
story is something that was just one of
the bright spots of this weekend and I
think you're gonna be excited to chat
about it the Jonas Brothers pay homage
for risky business Greece and say
anything and what a man gotta do video
okay so not only did the Jonas Brothers
put out an incredible incredible song
this weekend they put out the video to
match it okay I totally agree but I
haven't have some problems with it I
have a few thoughts of how it could have
been tweaked what hashtag where is
Danielle Jonas like they totally got
shafted shafted like they didn't even
get into the video I think the bridge
and then they were totally irrelevant
and like Nick Jonas just being like so
there's he with a sighs like I just
can't stop like I disagree you don't
work that hard on thighs like that just
to not show them off it was just so
obvious like I'm sure Kevin and Joe have
nice eyes too like they're not running
around with her thighs and then Kevin I
mean Nick tweeting like that's why we
can't forget leg day mm-hmm that's funny
I just like I'm so over him okay I'm so
under him and they were so cringy like
no they were perfect she had looked
stunning
I'm sorry out of the fact that like she
is literally Miss Universe like she I
feel like she could have been a royal
she was hooniverse
yes she simply could have been wrong and
she's Anna Jonas Brothers music video
like in her undies I'm so [ __ ] here
for it I can't tell you no I just don't
know how you could watch that video and
not think that you know Sophie and Joe
are the number one couple of this group
number one couple in this group but my
my only two notes about the video like I
really do think it would have been
benefited if it was directed by Hannah
Lux Davis like but it was a Joseph Kahn
product
and Joseph Kahn is premium he's up there
I just like wasn't feeling I feel like
it could have been even better and - I
wish the whole thing had been greased
because the song is so grease grease
were the best parts they could have
reenact anybody's just distress showed
up at the dance I totally agree and say
anything we're distracting and you'd
have been 100 percent grease and then
they could have used those themes for a
different video Jackie that is such a
brilliant analysis saying kiddin agree
more thank you I mean the cha-cha
DiGregorio of it all it's just too much
for me because she was one of the most
iconic characters in film history and
then so we Turner's out here playing her
with black hair so he's her name's
playing ChaCha and Tina get you a girl
who can do both and it's like they
understand that Sophia's actress of our
generation and they're putting that to
great use and then when they then they
all ended up at the dance and like it
kind of Jenna make sense no one like
these two couples on the end our green
screen distributor and so it's like did
they not maybe they didn't want to film
it together and then that makes me
scared like the Jonas Brothers just got
back together like we can't deal with a
separation that is like an interesting
albeit like a little paranoid assumption
but I got a degree okay no but think
about it why did they give the wrong
part of the video where they're all
together the couples are green screened
they did play on the band stage together
yeah but the wives weren't there for
right so is it the wives aren't getting
along that's what this video made me
think that's very interesting and like I
don't want to be paranoid but I kind of
agree you know but it was such a good
video and I just want to say that the
song is so good and so cute like kind of
all the music is just now like all about
like being I hate when people like who
like obviously don't write their own
music are like singing about like
[ __ ] in the club when like they're
married with kids you know hunt you
predict their music is now reflective of
the time period in their lives like what
a man gotta do to be totally locked up
by you like so cute so sweet and really
reflective of the stage there and in
their lives and I think that's beautiful
I think it's so I think it's so
beautiful it's really hard for me though
to like talk about the Jonas Brothers
specifically like Joe and Sophie because
like when I watch them and then I talk
about them like I really realize like in
a very serious way like I'm completely
in love with Joe Jonas and like it's
really hard for me I know I'll like
never marry him
yeah I'm like happy for him like I'm
happy for my marriage too but like I'm
really in love with Joe Jonas
yeah I feel like I think that's okay
yeah it's like it's just like every time
I talk right I mean like watch him
I realize that gets beyond a crush like
I really love him like I have feelings
right it's like I like I like like him
you know I don't just like it I
understand okay
and it's hard for me it's like I need
any no I live in my own world and I I've
recently come to grips with the fact
like there's no like future with Joe
John is waiting for me like I need so
just understand me anything can happen
so churro you can go from being on
Hallmark to being royal and you honestly
you being with Joe Jonas like it's less
crazy than that
I completely agree Wow totally
reinvigorated I hope Ben does listen
today's episode honestly Ben never
listens like I could say whatever I want
on here like I could literally show my
butthole and he would be like how was
the show today
anything okay our fourth story like wow
switching gears in a major way is really
sad because Taylor Swift has revealed
her mom Andrea has been diagnosed with a
brain tumor Taylor Swift revealed that
her mother Andrea Swift who was battling
breast cancer has been diagnosed with a
brain tumor
the singer 30 made the candid revelation
in her vanity cover story in which she
discusses her forthcoming Netflix
documentary miss Americana which put
will premiere at the Sundance Film
Festival I guess we're going to Sundance
Andrews cancer returned while the
popstar was filming explaining she was
going through chemo and that's a hard
enough thing for a person to go through
she added while she was going through
treatment they found a brain tumor and
the symptoms of what a person goes
through when they have a brain tumor is
nothing like what we've ever been
through with her cancer before so it's
just been a really hard time for us as a
family that is [ __ ] horrible like
Andrea just cannot catch a break not
only is she going to bring breast cancer
for this second time she was in
remission and recently was diagnosed
again now gonna get a brain tumor like
oh my god like that's so sad and you
know obviously like everyone's
relationship with their mom is super
close but like Taylor Swift specifically
like is obsessed with her mom more than
the average 30 year old and I just
really feel really sad about this and it
makes me like not want to watch a
documentary because I don't want to cry
ya know it seems like it's gonna be a
heavy documentary because she's on the
cover of variety I only saw the cover
from snitch's Instagram story she's
talking about new music politics it's
like a big cover and then the
documentary looks major yeah the cover
art like came out it's perfection
yeah I'm really excited for you and
Margo I'm also excited for myself you
know she never talks about her mom so I
am glad that she's like opening up but
at the same time I hate that people feel
celebrity specifically feel like they
have to talk about this stuff like I
totally am Telescope's number one fan I
want to be inside
at all times like I'm okay not knowing
this you know what I mean yeah well I
think maybe she would have kept it to
herself but they did happen to be
filming and you know so she's addressing
it but the fact that she you know takes
her time to talk about these things like
in her own time I think it's it's nice
and it gives her time to process and
people give her respect like they give
her like their space totally and it
really just goes to show you you never
know what people are going through like
so true
you know the peak of your career like
you just never know Church here True
Jackson VP um speaking of you never know
what people are going through our fifth
and final story is celebrity news Meghan
King Edmonds is making the headlines
have you heard this news yet I've been
seeing her like all over the place and
as much as I want to like empathize with
her she really annoys me okay I
understand but this story is just too
crazy to ignore about the woman of the
threesome
yeah Meghan King Edmonds says her ex Jim
Edmonds is dating a woman they had a
threesome with okay now I she's a woman
and just to give you the context by the
way Meghan King Edmonds started a
podcast which is how this is so happy
for her love little podcast news when
they got married and Jim like has had
this like you know he's obviously you
know big swinging dick and has this past
and she wanted to you know embrace it
yeah and he wanted a37 so she said okay
and they found one of her friends who
she felt really comfortable having a
baby in the crib Meghan's friend and she
said they only had the threesome once
but like ever asked like after that like
she felt like something was off and that
like she was the outsider when it came
to the two of them and now they're
dating they were just in cabo for his
birthday I did not see them I didn't
know I should be looking for them
I I probably was could have seen them I
mean first rule I've heard of having a
threesome mister never supposed to do it
with someone you know like you're
supposed to never see the person again
um so to me this is just like a huge
mistake on both of their parts not that
I'm putting blame but like it is both of
their faults too I just I don't know I
so hard for me to not just like blame
the woman here because I want to be a
woman who supports other women be like
what are you doing well inviting a woman
into your bed and then like when you
know the type of husband you have and
his past and then also bringing like a
hot young nanny like I just I just have
the nanny didn't look I just think you
know I just think you know I think yeah
well I think what's she was fine with
the threesome and but now what's like
hard for her is that there
dating and that her friend who was her
friend like didn't tell her that she was
about to embark on a journey like with
her ex-husband no I know but it's like
we're so far past that I do I know we're
so sorry path to your husband now you
worry about her telling you like so far
house like common decency is like I
can't even comment on this or like give
advice because I can't really do this
whatsoever you know yeah I just it's
also not like when they were together he
was the picture of the perfect person
perfect husband like I feel like so many
other people like saw it coming and yes
what we see on TV isn't always the
reality but it's like I feel like for so
long she ignored all of his bad
qualities and now it's like it's all
coming out it's like this isn't
surprising ya know and it's like it's
such a piece of [ __ ] if we know what
type of guy Jim Edmonds is I have to
assume his wife did you know and it's
like if I could see this coming I think
you could have seen it to him oh but
it's just a shame that like the most
interesting era of her life like where
she's been in the news now more than
ever like she's not a housewife you know
when we had to put up with like the
boring years except that she did solve
the Brooks cancer situation she
predicted it and that will always be her
legacy I wonder if she'll make a return
because she moved to st. Louis because
of Jim so and he's taking the house so
is she gonna be bad I think it's a
possibility I wouldn't sleep me down for
her I liked her as a house she's on this
most recent season for a minute on the
train yeah and she wear that jumpsuit
looks pretty she wear the hat yeah you
know the blogger hat the conductor hat
yeah so you never know anything can
happen if you just believe okay we're
gonna get to camp toes questions there
anything else that we just wanted to
chat about anything that you watched her
that you did no I didn't watch I didn't
watch The Bachelor and I don't think I'm
a much better pump pearls like I'm on a
really strict like 7 p.m. bedtime
um and I just put in me first you know
I'm listening to the bloggers self-care
is so important so import so I think
that I'm just gonna like lead with love
this week and see where that takes me
mm-hmm yes should we jump into the Kim
toasts I'm ready I've got the questions
pulled up okay well I'll go before we
jump into our Kim chose to Q&A if you
have any questions head over to our
Instagram story the segment is brought
to you by zip recruiter it's a new year
the perfect opportunity to take your
business to the next level by hiring the
right people but finding qualified
candidates can be
challenging zip recruiter dot-com slush
toast makes it easy they send your job
to over a hundred of the web's leading
job boards but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply to your job as
an application comes in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match they're so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
right now our listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter dot-com / toast
that's zip recruiter comm slash toast
toas tea zip recruiter comm / toast
check it out new year you want to keep
growing your team but you need the right
tools to keep hiring and streamlining
your efficient it says that's where zip
recruiter dot-com / toast comes in
sign-on zip amazing ok we have that we
have a lot of really great great
questions I learned great questions
running the gamut from everything that's
logistical but also like emotional um a
lot of people asking about age like am I
too old to come from 30 no there is
absolutely no like I'm 30
there's no age maximum but there is an
age minimum you have to be 21 plus
because that's like there are no rules
at camp toast but that is the only and
most enforced rule yes don't try to come
with a fake ID so and try to come with a
fake ID like it'll just be so bad for
you I'm like you'll have to go home and
like you won't have a fight and I mean
that hasn't happened yet but like don't
even try it don't do it it's not
happening like at all um is it a lame if
the toasty mama wants to come to campus
no like leave me at home ya know and
we've also been nasty about this 21500 I
thought you meant like a girl and her
mom oh no cuz I've been telling me chef
a mom bunk Oh totally yeah I know but
like if you're our mom like come come
there's if you are a mom you want to
bring your mom there's Apple like I feel
like the median age at camp anyway is
3035 yeah it's not less than 30 you know
people think it's like junk teenagers
running around it's actually not it's a
mature women having meaningful
conversations yeah how long is camp camp
is from is Memorial Day weekend it
starts on Friday afternoon and it ends
on
Monday morning and it's just like the
best weekend of your life built into the
price of your ticket is lodging for
Friday night Saturday night Sunday night
meals alcohol beer and wine throughout
the day all you can eat all you can
drink all the fun you can have all the
friends you can have all the scene
activity it's just all there like the
minute you set foot you can if you have
a car you can go places if you wanted to
but you never need to leaving you never
need to buy anything once you're there
yeah there's a coffee bar every morning
there's a corn stand yet an endless
supply of snacks because I'm there and
that's literally my job
totally is it weird if I'd go by myself
lol not at all and I actually think the
people who have the best time and get
the most out of camp are mean evil who
go by themselves and put themselves out
there and like it's nice to go with a
friend to have someone to lean on but
when you really like just throw yourself
into it I think that's when you get the
most out of camp I think that's a
question we get the most about camp like
is it weird to go alone and I can't
stress enough like how much better it is
to go alone you think obviously like
having a crutch have a friend is always
great I think the risk reward is just
like it's higher yeah as an adult it's
where you find yourself in certain like
social situations where you need to like
make new friends when I get out of your
comfort zone and those are really good
like social skills to have and I think
camcos can be great for that
how are bunks determined so when you buy
your ticket today there's a few
questions that we ask you um one of them
is if there's any toasters that you want
to bunk with you can request people or
don't want to bunk with yeah that too
you can request people that you want to
bunk with and we'll put you in a bunk
with them or if you're coming alone and
you don't know anyone we'll put you in a
bunk like based on like stalking you and
maybe figuring out might be friends
that's what we did the first year before
we like knew anyone we were looking up
like where people lived and we did like
a southern bunk or there were so many
people from Alabama we threw them all in
one bun like people who are moms you put
them in a bunk turns out none of them
are moms I guess all their pictures were
just with their nieces and nephews yeah
I bet I remember checking I said like
bunk stalking everyone just like trying
to find like a common thread between
like all these random people from like
Albuquerque to Pittsburgh like it was
really funny yeah this year we do it a
little bit more streamlined because so
many people are returning campers yeah
so there's like returning campers bunk
there's new bunks you can request if you
come with a friend you want to be with a
certain group of people also there's
enough spacing of that especially for
the male campers you can get your own
bunk if you want yeah and if you wanted
to come like with your boyfriend husband
girlfriend and the two of you wanting
your own
we could accommodate that that hasn't
happened yet someone asks if they're
coming with their GBS can he be in the
bunk with her um yeah and we can also
give the two of you your own bunk oh so
if you are something that sounds so fun
if you want your own bunk like some
people you know have sleep apnea
sleepwalking sleep farting um you can
have your own bunk yeah so the camps
technically holds like 650 people but
we're maxing at 300 we don't want it to
be too crowded and then that gives us
extra bugs yes exactly how much is it
canvass six hundred and eighty dollars
before taxes and fees but that's six
hundred eighty dollars gets you
everything everything that you need yeah
it gives you a bunk for the weekend food
alcohol oh my god well I saw a lot of
questions about the bunk like how much
stuff can you bring and I just want to
recommend last year so many people like
just went to Walmart or Target before
camp and got like cheap and crates
blankets pillows because it makes the
bed so much more comfortable and then we
all left them and donated them everyone
kind of dropped off their bedding at the
office and then the campgrounds donate
it's like a local shelter which i
thought was really cool so you can spend
like an extra thirty dollars on bedding
and then it's a donation yeah um there
are beds with mattresses full disclosure
like they're not the most comfortable
beds in the world but um you know a
great I I made my bed pretty comfortable
last year and it was it made the biggest
difference the year before I literally
needed a cane after camp I didn't walk
but I got an egg crate from Target I got
a little blanket a little down comforter
got myself a fan I spent my sleep it's
good stuff um is it vegetarian friendly
I mean yes like I eat vegetarian at camp
and there's more than enough food
there's a lot of different options yep
will there be white cloud this year no
it is beer and wine only and that is for
your benefit you get it's for your
safety it's you just trust like everyone
is very happy that there's no tequila
and vodka like the bar opens at 12:00 so
I think it's just beer and wine for you
guys I think you're gonna be just fine
beer and wine and you'll thank us when
you get there
yeah um what's the best way to get there
so if you live in the tri-state area the
best way to get there is to drive there
is parking on site it's about 25 or 30
dollars a day and then you have a car if
you need to go anywhere or you can fly
in there's a lot of surrounding airports
that are in the ticket information and
they'll be in your confirmation email
and also like carpooling with fellow
campers a lot of people
really created some people drive up
together and some people will like you
know maybe have a toaster pick them up
from the airport and drive so also once
you get your ticket you'll get the link
to the Facebook group for cam tous 3 and
likes you can spend the next 4 months
talking to other tours and like figuring
out maybe some of you live near each
other
that's where well lands are made that's
where plans are made I'm so excited I
love when the group like starts to come
together where did the idea for camp
toast originate it originated on the
toast it originated on the toast and I
think I tracked it back to when we were
in Nashville and we went out after our
show with a bunch of toasters and we
were like I felt like camp yeah and we
were so hungover that we were just like
being weird and I was like but what if
we did a camp so and then I was like no
I'm gonna I'm gonna call Howard you
could do my word it was something that
was a possibility so we just kept going
I can't believe that first one like that
was the like that was the most nervous
I've ever been yeah that was how he
lured him a guy the craziest thing we've
ever done
for sure um mm-hmm
a lot of similar questions there's no
such thing as - well - oh I just can't
stress that we are ranging from 21 to 53
the last few summers can you buy two
tickets wanting to purchase for you and
a friend yes you can buy two tickets ooh
will anything be different from years
prior yeah a few like scheduling
differences will be different we've
spoken about how like there hasn't been
like a formal meeting great which I
think we didn't do because it sounded so
conceited but so many people were like
spending the whole weekend with us and
actually never even got a picture um so
just to set aside like a little bit
amount of time make sure everyone gets
like a premium ring like photo just to
get that out of the way yeah they don't
have to like worry about like you know
it schedule it in for yourself I think
we'll definitely shift up the schedule a
little bit it will also depend on the
weather but we also have a few things
that we're trying to get done but
obviously you know we don't count our
chickens before they had to go we have
some exciting things development it's
gonna be really good you guys yeah also
the way we're gonna do bunking this year
is gonna be a little different I mean
we're just it's gonna be a little bit
better more efficient yeah more
efficient I'm sure so the bunking is
also very laissez-faire like if you're
in a bunk and you're not feeling it just
talk about yeah each bunk will have like
a few open beds in it so if you want to
leave a bunker join a bunk there will be
a bed for flexibility like you're not
our prisoner who's got ready money each
bunk I think holds like eight to ten
people and we never put more than six so
there's a free
is the prestigious dr. Theodore for
chairman going to be there yes he will
be manning the infirmary it's important
to have a doctor on site
I think Thea was the absolute best part
of camp those two yeah I mean it was
definitely like a lot of work um maybe
I'll bring like his Walker who's like
the O's best friend we could just like
man the other holy good we're gonna go
with our friends and they did a great
team everyone was really all hands on
deck I mean oh it was great what set the
camp has a dog and he hangs out in the
office and he has so many toys and
treats and so if you had someone to play
with and I could leave him in the office
like when we were busy it was so amazing
he'll just like loves to be you know in
the greener pastures and that's exactly
the camp is so much grass also if you
haven't checked out our YouTube video of
our camp toast recap from last summer
check it out it's so good
yeah it really gives you a feel for
what's gonna happen um people ask about
if there's ever gonna be camp in the
northwest like literally we have
absolutely no plans to do that I don't
even know where we would start like this
is it as yes camped oh yeah I get so
every time I do a mean grade like when
is West Coast camp toast and as much as
I would love it just because it rhymes
um I don't think it's good it would be
good it's just not in like any sort of
plans that we have so if you are
interested in coming to camp toast like
now is your chance it's gonna be so much
fun
tickets available 12 o'clock patron calm
such the morning toast then well there's
a password yeah the website is password
protected so patreon members will get
the password at 12 o'clock everyone else
will get it tomorrow it's pretty very
exciting pretty nice yeah
alright so camp toast 12 o'clock Eastern
Time so that's in about 30 minutes what
time's up
uh in 45 minutes okay 45 minutes check
it out thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the Millennial
morning show where we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it
Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio I
her videocast box oh the places so check
us out subscribe to us wherever you
listen to podcast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys so much
have an amazing day
[Music]